I'd like to give you a progress report
on something that I've been working on
the safe project in order to put it in
context we first need to talk about the
web anyone ever heard of the web the
world wide web anybody I'm not surprised
that a few hands went up because it's
the most important application delivery
system in the history of the world
almost everybody on the planet is on the
web a huge amount of Commerce and social
interaction and everything is happening
on the web and that's kind of a problem
because the web was not designed to do
any of the things that it's doing it was
intended to be a simple even primitive
document retrieval system a hypertext
retrieval system and we went way way
past that but we didn't really work it
out when we must pass the original goals
and so as a result the web is really
difficult to develop for much more
difficult than it should be and it has
some really serious problems and for me
the worst of those problems deal with
security as we're doing putting more and
more of our lives online more and more
of our wealth more of our meaning and
it's the web is capable of betraying us
and allowing all of that to be given up
and that's a bad thing so the history of
security and computers really starts
with passwords the very first computers
were secured by men with guns and it was
really effective the first computers
were designed for military applications
or code breaking weapon design that kind
of thing and there are sentries around
the machines who made sure that nobody
could get access to them who shouldn't
have had access to them and that worked
pretty well until the advent of disk
drives
when disk drives happened then there was
now a need for security because any
program could potentially get to any
information that's on the disk drive
information that it might not be
entitled to its becomes especially a
problem when time share
happens time sharing was a service the
first computing is a service service in
which people would buy a piece of time
on a mainframe and you could have lots
of people dialing into the same
mainframe using it simultaneously
and passwords we were required to make
sure that nobody was getting on the
mainframe without paying for their time
and also to make sure that they weren't
getting access to other accounts that
they were not authorized to do when
personal computing is invented we forgot
all of those lessons and we started over
the first pcs didn't have passwords and
that was fine until they start to get
hard drives and then floppy based
viruses start to go around and then we
start to Network them and then we
learned again everything that we had
forgotten from the time sharing era the
first time security seems to be involved
in the design of the web is in RFC 1738
which is a document which first
describes URLs and in that document they
describe a format for a URL which
contains a password which will be sent
over the internet in the clear and at
least one of the authors of that RFC
recognized that this was a really bad
idea and he inserted this sentence the
use of URLs containing passwords that
should be secret is clearly unwise which
is an amazing bit of understatement
but that's where the web starts so what
so in order to look at how we're going
to fix the web we first have to look at
what's wrong with it web now many of you
are making a living on the web and you
may have never worked in any other
environment
the web is all you know and so I'm gonna
say things which are going to be
shocking and hurtful which are not
directed at you at all okay I'm talking
about the web I'm not I mean no offense
to anybody here or out there so what's
wrong with the web well though the first
problem is it's in it's in security
which is because it was not designed to
be a secure assist
we tried to add security after the fact
and that rarely works I also have a
problem with its complexity because it
was not intended to be what it turned
out to be
we've been patching it and adding stuff
and adding stuff without a lot of
foresight we just keep adding more and
more stuff so you get an increasingly
big pile of stuff and given the way web
standards work it's impossible to remove
stuff from that pile so and the pile is
full of Swiss cheese holes and other
things and it's not repairable all we
can do is lump more stuff on top of it
w3c does not have the power to reduce
that pile all they can do is make it
bigger so let's look specifically at
what's in the web and what's wrong with
it
so we'll start with HTTP the hypertext
transport protocol I see it as being
three things first is it's a data format
for expressing key value pairs that's
how you describe a request or a response
and it's a very fussy key value pair
format I think there are much much
better formats for expressing those
sorts of things it's also a negotiation
protocol the first web browsers were
very incompetent with respect to image
formats protocols and so on and so image
might be requested and the browser and
the server will be in a conversation
about well I don't know about JPEGs do
you know about gifts and they'll do that
and try to figure out if they could and
we're still sending that on every
request so we're wasting human huge
amounts of bandwidth on that and then
it's a request response protocol you
make a request you wait the response
comes back you disconnect and you're
done which made a lot of sense when the
web was just a simple document retrieval
system you get a document you get it
back you disconnect it then you might
click and go to another place but that's
not what web pages look like today right
you might have hundreds of assets on
that page you've got glow to script
we'll have no script and other scripts
of images another name another image
stylesheet and so on might
hundreds of those and for each one
you'll request a thing then you'll wait
and then you can request the next one
and then you wait and so you can waste
an enormous amount of network bandwidth
just waiting for this stuff so to
mitigate that browsers will open up
multiple connections to the same server
just so they can get a little bit more
activity going there on the HTTP but
that adds another level of complexity
it's not really a solution then there's
DNS the domain name system this was a
well-intentioned thing so that people
wouldn't have to remember IP addresses
which is a terrible user experience that
instead you could type in the name of a
server and it will connect you to or
give tell you what the IP number is you
can connect to it unfortunately it's not
compatible with compatible with the
worlds trademark systems and so there's
constant legal bickering and there's
security problems with it in domain
squatting and similar names which can
catch people accidentally and there's
DNS poisoning attacks and other things
like that
there's SSL secure socket layer but the
people at Netscape wanted to put
commerce onto the web and they
recognized that they needed some way of
encrypting the traffic and so they came
up with SSL unfortunately it's really
really complicated and it's very slow it
requires too many round trips in order
to get a connection going on and it has
big security problems we've been doing
SSL for 20 years now it seems every
month another huge error is found in SSL
it doesn't seem to be converging on
something that's correct it's just it's
awful and one of the things that makes
it awful is its dependence on
certificate authorities the most famous
of their certificate authority is
Verisign so if you get a certificate
from Verisign that's supposed to prove
something but the only thing that really
proves is that somebody gave some money
to Verisign so I don't know who they are
I don't know why I should trust them but
that's how the thing works but even
worse than that there are hundreds of
other certificate
authorities who I know even less about
who I trust less but your browser trusts
them equally many of them have already
been corrupted then there's HTML the
hypertext markup language is HTML a good
thing or a bad thing that depends on
what you want to do if what you want to
make is simple technical documents that
can link to other technical documents
it's really not very good its fussy its
cryptic it's ugly its brittle that's why
we invented markdown languages markdown
languages do the thing that HTML was
intended to do and do it much much
better now if your intention is to
deliver interactive applications through
the web it's terrible because it wasn't
designed to do that at all and we've
been struggling with trying to figure
out how to make it work
and the state of the art seems to be
templating which I hate templating
because for a lot of reasons one is it's
the XSS attack vector it is possible to
design a templating system which does
not expose people to XSS attacks but
apparently it's never happened because
the attacks still happen every day it
tends to create terrible architectures
because everything in the stack is
focused on generating HTML I've seen it
go so crazy that there is HTML template
inhabiting in browsers and I'm not
kidding it's that stuff's going on it's
crazy the thing I hate most about
templating is it's a trap because
everything is focused on HTML we can't
ever get rid of it we can't ever move on
to something else because there's HTML
dependency going all the way back to the
database how do you correct that stuff
then there's the Dom the document object
model which is the API that the browser
presents to JavaScript it is the worst
API ever imagined I'm not telling you
anything you don't know right it's it's
painful to use it's at the wrong level
of abstraction it's not specified
adequately enough that portability
problems that
insecure awful awful thing then there's
CSS crappy style sheets so I don't need
to tell you what's wrong with CSS then
finally there's JavaScript JavaScript is
a hot mess
javascript was designed in ten days and
it turns out you can make a lot of
mistakes in 10 days and yet there is a
little bit of genius in JavaScript and
that's why it's I should it should be
redeemed I think javascript because of
that little bit of goodness has
unexpectedly become the world's most
popular functional programming language
nobody imagined that ever happening
especially the guy who designed it
because if you know that was the fate
I'm sure you would have done a better
job but if you strip away all of the
badness in JavaScript and there's a huge
amount of it and tc39 is powerless to
ever remove it all they can do is add
more crap on top of it and they're busy
doing that for you but if you work with
a well designed subset of JavaScript you
can write good programs and so I'm gonna
keep that piece but I want to move away
from everything else so I'm proposing
coming up with a thing which repairs the
web and I'm not the first to have
proposed this many have tried this
before Microsoft Apple Adobe Oracle and
many other companies large and small saw
the problems inherent in the web and
thought this is an opportunity we can
capture it or replace it and take over
the world you know
their technology is always better
because they could see what the web got
wrong and make stuff right most of the
solutions that they came up with were by
design not open because their goal was
to close the web to capture it to turn
it into a proprietary system and
fortunately from my point of view they
all failed
and they failed not because their
technology wasn't much better than what
we have on the web but because they did
not have a suitable transition plan they
did not figure out how to convince
everybody in the world to go to the new
proprietary platform so that turns out
to be a key part of this so what I
propose is to upgrade the web I want to
keep it doing the things that it does
well in place not changing it at all but
add a new mode to it which allows us to
take advantage of new kinds of
applications which give us the security
and the ease of development that we need
so there's a brilliant guy named Zuko
who has a theory about names he says
that there are three interesting
properties that a name could have it
could be human meaningful it could be
securely unique and it could be globally
decentralized and you can get at most
two of these characteristics from any
name and the one that the web chose was
human meaningful at least to the extent
where a URL make sense to humans but I'm
more concerned with security at global
scale and so I'm taking the other two
instead so of the new system that I'm
proposing is rooted in using 521 bit
private or public keys as globally
unique identifiers so that with this new
system we will never again send a
password over the network encrypted or
in the clear instead we will use public
key cryptography as it was originally
intended in order to secure our
applications so to remind you about how
cryptography works we've got two major
techniques there is the symmetric stuff
which tends to be used for a link
encryption where you've got a symmetric
key which is used to both encrypt
plaintext and to decrypt ciphertext and
then we've got the asymmetric stuff
which is the public key stuff in which
you've got two keys one is used for
encrypting and the other is used for
decrypting
so in this model the public key is
shared with everybody in the world
anybody you ever might want to interact
with they should know your public key
that's how they'll know it's you and the
way you prove its you is that you are
the only person in the world in
possession of your private key which
means only you can decrypt the messages
that they encode for you having that we
don't need passwords so we'll also
provide trust management because people
cannot manage 521 bit keys and IP
addresses just possible so we'll provide
a way where you can keep knowledge of
all the people and organizations you
have relations with and keep them out in
the cloud some safe place and you can
give them your own private pet names
which no one else's see which will allow
you to know who each of these guys is
our computational model is based on a
thing called a vat of that as a
computational container you can put
things into it the things that you put
in there can't get out and they can't
communicate with anything else except
through JSON communication to specific
endpoints so that allows us to take toad
from a third party or any party and put
it in that thing and allow it to do
useful computation for us but constrain
it so that it can't get loose and do bad
things so that having vats which we can
connect together over adjacent channels
allows us to have a model of computation
in which we have cooperation under
mutual suspicion which means we can have
many parties working together for the
benefit of the user without being able
to get over on each other which will
enable lots of new interesting stuff so
we've begun implementing and releasing
some of this stuff the first piece is
called safe node it is a module adding
cryptographic services to no js' it
provides elliptic curve 521 which we use
for for the public keys it es 256 which
we use for link encryption and sha 3 256
for hashing
now all of these are much stronger than
are needed for this application but I am
paranoid and so I'm using cryptography
which is stronger than we need that is
not in any way a guarantee that we got
the security part of this right but I
think it's a necessary precondition and
we especially paid a lot of attention to
random numbers because you will generate
your own key pair I don't trust any
service to do that for you because it
means they will know your private key
and I don't trust them to not hold on to
it and may be forced to compromise you
later
so but in order for you to generate your
own 520 bit 521 bit key pair we have to
make sure that you've got really good
random numbers because if the random
numbers are if not sufficient quality
then they're going to be collisions and
and that's not good so we're adding an
entropy collection module to safe node
and it will harvest entropy from the
operating system but I don't trust the
operating systems including operating
systems that haven't arrived yet to give
me sufficient entropy to allow us to
generate good private keys so we will
also open up your microphone only do
this once when we install the stuff and
we'll listen for a few seconds we're not
paying attention to what's going on
we're just looking for noise in fact you
don't even need a microphone in there we
just need stuff coming out of the audio
converter and we'll do a similar thing
with your camera we'll turn that on and
watch it for just a few frames we're not
actually looking at you in fact I would
highly recommend you get a piece of
masking tape and put it over the camera
thing on your laptop because you don't
know who's watching so and that works
fine for us because again we're not
looking for pictures we're just looking
for noise and we'll assemble all of that
in randomness and use that to generate
your your private keys then we've also
just released the safe protocol the safe
protocol provides for secure chasin over
TCP and it's an inefficient
session protocol so one of the things I
like best about the safe protocol well
first off it uses Jason right I like it
but I also really like the way we do our
ham shake so Alice and Bob want to make
a safe connection Alice
starts knowing her own public key and
private key because everybody knows
their own pair and she also knows Bob's
public key because that's how she knows
Bob Bob also starts knowing his own
public can private key he does not know
who's about to connect to him he might
have had a previous experience with
Alice but he doesn't know that she's
about to call so Alice will generate a
random handshake key the 256 bit session
key which we'll use for the next step
and she will send a message to Bob the
message will be in the form of a Jason
message it will contain a safe property
which tells us what version of the
protocol were running today we're at
version 1 and this is all of the
negotiation that's going to go on about
formats if the server decides safe one
is not safe anymore
it'll send back a message saying you
need to move up to safe 2 or safe 3 and
then disconnect so we intend this to be
a very brittle mechanism the SSL took
the other approach that they allow
compromised cryptography to remain in
play for decades
turns out which allows attackers to
choose the weakest crypto options
available yet and use those to attack
we're not going to do that we're going
to have a very brittle system everybody
is going to have to move up within a
very small window the next thing in the
in the Jason message is going to be
Alice's handshake key encrypted with
Bob's public key so that only Bob will
be able to find that and then Alice will
use that handshake key to encrypt her
public key this is for privacy so nobody
can see
who is trying to connect to Bob they can
probably guess because they can see
Alice's IP address but we're gonna
pretend like there's still privacy in
the world there's not but we're gonna
pretend so Bob receives the message and
after decoding it he now knows the
handshake key and he uses that to obtain
Alice's public key so he now knows who's
trying to connect to him if he's had
previous experience with Alice he can
load all of that stuff in if not then
Alice may be a new customer for someone
and so he'll be prepared for setting up
a new account or whatever he's going to
do and now he's going to send a message
back he's going to generate a random
session key which is another 256 bit
number and he's going to send back a
message which is encrypted using Alice's
handshake key which will contain the
session key encrypted with Alice's
public key when Alice receives this
message she now knows the session key
and she knows that she is connected to
Bob no one else could have sent her the
session key except for Bob because he
had the private key that she could not
have gotten this stuff if he had not had
her H in his private key so she knows
who he is and when Alice from now on all
messages will be encrypted with the
session key and when Bob receives the
first message from Alice he will know
that it was in fact Alice and it was in
fact Alice who initiated the connection
we established this in one round-trip
which is a really nice thing for
performance because CPUs have gotten a
lot faster so computation is almost
infinite now and we can expect network
bandwidth to improve because the pipes
are gonna get fatter but they're not
going to get shorter Moore's law does
not apply to the speed of light and so
ultimately the only way to reduce
latency is to reduce round trips so
being able to set this up in one
round-trip is pretty close to optimal
it's going to be a full-duplex protocol
it's not a request response like HTTP
any either party can send a message at
any time you can send as many messages
as you want and either party can
initiate so we can get very different
patterns of flow than we get in the
current web model and that will enable
new classes of applications what they
used to call push where if the server
has something you need to know the
server doesn't have to wait for you to
ask it can just send it right along and
because we can have all of the stuff
going in both directions simultaneously
we also take better advantage of the
network bandwidth we'll provide three
ways of sending a message there'll be
the normal send in which you can get a
callback which will tell you if the
message got delivered or delivery failed
for example if you're on a a portable
device and you lose network connectivity
we'll have a reliable send which will
attempt to send the message and if it
doesn't get there will again because of
a disconnected perhaps we will persist
it will write it out to storage and we
will then attempt it to retry it and
once the connection is established maybe
in tomorrow or next week whenever we can
get back to that server will then send
that message as you can
so that's reliable then there's
unreliable sound we need to come up with
a better name for this this is for doing
telemetry where I've got a status
message and I want the other party to
know this is what's going on right now
and if it gets delayed we'll just throw
it away that we we don't want to end up
sending all of the stuff we just want to
send the last one and all of that's
available on github too then the next
step is we're going to implement safe
resource management in which we will
implement a retrieval system in which we
access assets not by name but by their
hash so we'll take a hash of a resource
and you'll say I want the thing that
corresponds to this 256 bit number
this length and you'll get that thing
it's guaranteed you will get that thing
and nothing else and it has some really
interesting performance properties
because it doesn't matter where we find
it you know it could come from the
world's most evil server but as long as
the hash code matches it's alright the
next thing we're going to do is safe
apps so we're going to provide a way of
making apps that can run on a desktop or
in a mobile device which will be free of
HTML but we'll use JavaScript and will
be built on nodejs
and cute so who knows what cute is okay
great in the US nobody has any idea what
cute is so cute is a very nice
application framework that was developed
in Norway it is very capable but we're
only going to use a tiny part of it the
part that knows how to talk to the
screen and to IO devices and to GPUs so
this is the architecture for safe app in
cute we'll be running UI code so your
application will have a display presence
in which it will put stuff on the screen
and interact with the user and we want
to make it capable enough because it's
written in JavaScript we can do this so
that that display presence will work
correctly on very small screens very
large screens so we'll finally get that
thing right and the cute presence will
not have access to the network it will
not have access to the filesystem it
will only be able to talk to the logic
presence that's running in node we're
going to take node and we're going to
strip it way down to so we're gonna
remove almost everything from node
mainly for security reasons that we
don't have the resources to vet
everything that's in node there's way
too much so we're just gonna leave the
event loop and TCP and just a couple
other things we'll take out MPM because
it allows you to load anything from
anywhere you don't want that in a secure
system so we can get rid of that replace
it with something else and then that
thing will be able to talk to
cute you know we'll be able to talk to a
server so everything will be adjacent
messaging going through that our next
step will be to take that and bundle it
as a helper app so that it can run in a
web browser now initially the way it'll
work is you will have to download this
thing and install it into your web
browser and then anytime you hit a safe
URL and this new thing will pop up I'm
that will work for you because you all
understand how this stuff works it will
not work for most of humanity so but it
will allow you to get a preview of the
safe system and make a determination is
this something that we think we want to
go forward on or not you'll be able to
make an informed decision about that and
then we need to convince everybody else
in the world to go along with it as well
so the goal of the safe project is to
provide safe and effective relationship
management on the web and this is the
transition plan so step one I need to
convince one progressive browser maker
to integrate the safe helper app and it
should be an easy thing for them to do
because all they need to do is give us a
rectangle and we can put pixels on and
UI events and adjacent channel that can
talk to the browser and we will do
everything else ourselves so integration
should be really easy I don't know which
browser maker is likely to do this
pretty confident it's not going to be
Apple and probably not Google I think
most likely Mozilla Mozilla used to be a
technology leader and they've had
recently a tough time keeping up with
with the bigger companies this might get
them a chance to buy some new market
share similar thing going on with
Microsoft Microsoft has contributed a
lot of Technology good and some not not
good
and you know last year they released
their edge browser which is maybe one of
the best things they've ever done and no
one cares just think they're getting no
pick up on that at all they might want
to get on to safe
because that would again be another
thing that would help them to to get
interest then I need to convince one
secure site to require its customers to
use that browser I need to convince some
medical institution or government
institution or financial institution
somebody who has a big need for security
who is scared to death about transacting
stuff over the web today who's desperate
for a better alternative I need to
convince one of those guys to adopt save
and then we'll see what happens
assuming that goes successfully risk
mitigation will compel other secure
sites to do the same thing it's sort of
like penguins
when penguins are standing on the edge
of the ice floe and they've been on the
ice for a long time when they're really
hungry and they want to jump in the
water because there are fish in there
but they're also sharks leopard seals
and things in there that eat penguins
and so they're all looking over the edge
and they kind of push closer and closer
until finally one of them slips and
falls in and then everybody looks and if
he comes back up they all go in so I'm
hoping this is going to go like that but
then competitive pressure will move the
other browser makers to do this too they
don't want to be the last one who
doesn't provide safe interaction on the
web and then I think the whole world
will follow that you know because this I
think this is an unfounded claim I think
we're gonna have a much better
development model than you get on the
web so I think this should be attractive
to you I have no evidence to support
that claim so we'll just have to see how
this unrolls to see if I'm right or not
but you know everyone I think we can
convince everyone to go and nothing
breaks an up
opposing changing anything about how the
current web works so I have two modes of
web old mode and new mode and they will
both work in the same browser and for
most purposes users will not be able to
tell which is which
and I think that's why this transition
plan might work because all of the other
transition plans were attempting to
capture you as developers but they
completely lost sight of the audience
and the audience is the critical
population that we need to move over so
the old web was really good at
promiscuity you could click on something
having no idea what it was where it
would go and you end up in some place
and click on something else and go and
it did that with relatively low danger
and so you could go and discover a lot
of stuff you could surf the web and that
was great it becomes a problem when you
need to be able to go back and be
confident that you're actually going
back to the party you think you're going
back to it turns out the web does a
really poor job of that that's what the
new web is for for commitment that we
know who each other are and I want to
make sure that we're doing this and
we're not being spied on and we're not
gonna be subject to man-in-the-middle
attacks or confusion or phishing or any
of that stuff we're going to be able to
reliably transact and that will allow us
an internet of people which i think is
even more interesting than an internet
of things so it's difficult to make
secure software security is really
really hard you have to make sure that
the software does what it should which
is always a struggle right and but when
you're talking about security you also
have to make sure that it doesn't do
what it shouldn't and often it's hard to
know what that even means and so making
this stuff is really difficult and we
know that no software is initially
secure and so I'm pretty confident that
the first releases we have of our stuff
even though we're trying to be really
diligent
someone's got to point out something
really embarrassingly stupid that we did
and will will then you know gratefully
acknowledge that that discovery and try
to fix it and I'm hoping that we will
unlike ssl converge on something which
is good enough and I believe only a
minimal approach can produce software
that is eventually secure and we're
designing safe to be as minimal as we
can figure out how to do but still
allowed to be complete enough to make
the applications that we imagine so this
is the self project or the safe project
part one is done and on github the safe
node module for for nodejs part two is
done in on github part three is in
development now no forecast on one parts
four or five will be done they are much
more complicated than the first stuff so
it's going to take a while
one of the really great things about the
way I've been doing this project is no
one has asked me when's it going to be
done and I haven't volunteered it I have
an idea of when I think it should be
done but I'm not telling anybody and the
reason for that is that I deeply believe
that the making of good software takes
time and if you try to make it take less
time it takes more time and I don't want
to be pushed into a situation where we
release it quicker than we think we
should have to so we're gonna take our
time so much of what I'm talking about
is vaporware and it is extremely
irresponsible for me to be coming out in
public and talking about vapor and the
way that I'm doing but they invited me
to talk and said I can talk about
anything I wanted this is interesting to
me so this is what I'm talking about so
there's nothing new here there's no new
science no new technology this is just a
fresh packaging of ideas have been in
floating around for decades just trying
to put it in a way which I think will
make sense of the web finally so check
us out the safe project go to a safe
place
that'll direct you to get up so be safe
thank you and good night
[Applause]
thank you for your talk my question is
how do you plan to guarantee security or
make claims about the security of safe
as it is hosted in an unsafe environment
so my biggest fear about this system so
how your safety does not depend on the
safety of a server well or we have no
control over that so if some evil
government invades your server farm and
shoots all the good people and takes it
over nothing I can do about that right
that's just the way that goes I'm more
concerned with what happens on the
user's own devices and my biggest
concern there is being attacked from
beneath that there is no way that an
application can defend itself from a
malicious or incompetent operating
system and I think maybe all of our
operating systems are at least one of
those two things and so I'm hoping that
the operating systems will get their
acts together so that that particular
attack from beneath is no longer problem
the other thing I need to figure out if
if anybody is working on biometrics I
want a biometric system which is used
not just as a password replacement but I
want to know that the user is still in
control of the device so if someone
snatches the thing away from you I want
it to shut down
I wanted to know enough about you so
that it knows that you're no longer
control so someone's working on that I'm
not working on that but I need that so
get on it whoever you are okay
I have a question where or how can I get
the first public key because that sounds
like a big problem so how could I get
the public key of Bob so that's a good
question so we're gonna have a
transition device that gets you from the
old web to the new web and this is that
device so you've got a URL this is the
ugliest URL
ever designed it starts off with the
word safe I've been flirting with the
idea of changing it to web say web colon
because it seems really cool and nobody
else took it but right for now the
working title is safe and then there'll
be your 521 bit public key then an @
sign and then your 128-bit IP address
and then optionally a referral code
after that and you can get that from a
number of places one is you could get it
from Google you know if you go and ask
for your favorite site and Google says
we were pretty sure that it's this guy
it's hard to fool Google on this stuff
because they work on the big numbers and
it's really hard to fool them and that
page will contain this URL so when you
click on it it'll put you into safe mode
and it will send try to do the handshake
to that public key at that IP address
okay and there are other ways you could
do it too you could put it on a
billboard people could stop a picture of
it and connect to that we're assuming
that it'd be really hard for a miscreant
to put a public billboard out there you
know so anything which is hard for a bad
guy to do another way it might work is
you go to your bank and your banker will
hand you a card with a QR code on it and
a secret referral code and you click
that and that establishes your
connection with the bank so there are
lots of ways that you can get the first
public key and then from that point on
it all happens in the safe world okay so
I'm going to ask I'm here yeah I'm going
to ask half jokingly but so you said
that current web is a pile of layers of
security SSL is just a protocol for
choosing which security is the worst one
but actually you're betting now on
asymmetric cryptography and in safe
there is no way to replace it so
assuming in future we
all see a symmetric cryptography stops
being enough because of quantum
computers was something is there a way
to escape that or do we have to disable
safe know so you recall that the first
thing in the first handshake packet is
the safe level so if at some point we
determined that elliptic curve is no
longer trustworthy and we figure out
what the thing is that is we don't know
what that is yet but I'm assuming that
someone will figure it out by the time
we need it then it might be that safe
level two is that thing and then
everything migrates forward great thank
you
I was wondering in the in the QT based
UI solution are you trying to do
anything like with semantic tags or
anything to increase search ability or
is the text even discoverable by a
search engine it's not so all of this
stuff is going to be dark search engines
cannot see it nobody in the world even
NSA cannot see it unless they can
compromise at least one of your public
keys so if you want to have stuff which
is discoverable by Google you're gonna
have to keep it on the old web this
stuff is going to be they're going to be
blind to this stuff completely this
guarding HDB - all right taking ideas
from it I'm watching it I think Google
did some clever stuff with speedy the
difficult constraint that they had to
live with was they wanted to keep
basically the same schema as as SSL and
so they're stuck I mean there's only so
much of stuff they can do they can't do
the stuff that we can do because we're
doing a clean slate so I'm glad they're
doing it I wish them luck and in fact
they will make it easier or safer for
people to migrate from the old web to
the new web because we can have the HQ
PP to stuff which is the thing that
delivers the safe URL so I'm glad
they're doing that but it's not
sufficient for what I'm trying to do
okay honey question okay I don't know if
you're being rude or not I'm over here
sorry down here hello loud [ __ ] oh there
you are yeah the you it sounds like
we're doing this in a browser all right
now I have friends who've worked in
similar kind of projects for this before
and the conclusion they came to and
never they're working with browsers
what was really really hard to trust a
browser because we can all install note
of crappy extends into it and which
makes it extremely well untrustworthy
and I don't know how you're gonna get
past that and maybe you could explain
some of that yeah because we're gonna be
in our own space so the only way the
browser will talk to us is through
adjacent channel so okay that's that's
the only way in or out here so I want to
ask because you've mentioned several
times that we we were working on it so
who's backing it up is it like people
initiative - or or somehow consortium or
PayPal is very generously supporting
this project and they've been great they
have not asked for any particular
concessions they have not acted evilly
in any way they have not asked to be a
privileged site or
own home source or any of those things
they're just letting us do the work
which is and and they're letting us do
the work in open source so everything
we're doing we're releasing as we do it
so it's all out there if other people
would like to come in and work help us
on the effort that'd be wonderful you
know but yeah I'm very grateful to
PayPal for their support of the project
I have a question won't here one side be
affected by a restricted key size policy
and effectively shut down by some
governments I'm not paying any attention
to that that has an honest programmer
that's all I can do so I understand that
our security is perceived as a threat by
many governments and I'm hoping that
because we're doing this in the open
once it gets out there it's out there
and if the resistance decides we're
gonna go forward with safe there's no
way to stop it there's no singularity in
safe there's no one point where if we
shut that down the whole thing dies so
we'll see how that goes hello I have a
more practical question so you say that
you take note and the Qt it will be
integrated in the browser and you take a
lot of from note but what about v8 so is
it Mozilla for example would be okay
that you put the v8 inside a Mozilla or
you plan to rewrite on the different
JavaScript engines well we're using node
node has v8 built into it that's already
open sourced and licensed so we're just
using something that's already out there
but I mean it means that in browsers
it'll be kind of 2003 because there's a
another JavaScript engine in cute okay
so that but you know we got a lots of
memory now so
it's not the way I would have
architected it but that's kind of how it
turned out and I actually feel better
having our own JavaScript engine because
it means that if the browser gets
corrupted that doesn't automatically
mean that we got corrupted too so and in
the scheme of things that JavaScript
engine isn't all that big so my question
is going to overlap a little with the
previous one but why didn't you for
example choose to embed some portable
byte code instead of JavaScript because
that way we could have killed two birds
with one stone
get rid of JavaScript maybe I you can't
possibly believe me I consider that I'm
really looking forward to the day that
we put javascript down in the cold cold
ground but I don't think that day has
come yet and right now there's a whole
lot of momentum and I have a really
steep uphill job to do in this thing
trying to convince everybody in the
world to do another of my things you
know you only get so many chances at
that right so it's saying and a whole
new programming language I think that'd
be too much I don't think I could pull
that off so that's really good question
what if we did both added a new language
as well as doing JavaScript so many
years ago as an experiment Mozilla put
Python into Firefox and integrating that
wasn't too hard but they never exposed
it to the world and the reason they
didn't was they had just met 20 years
figuring out how to secure JavaScript
and I think that was a great language
but it was never tested that way and
they didn't want to have to start over
and be responsible for all the security
exploits from having done that and that
is the main reason why javascript is
going to live at least as long as the
web lives that you know earlier today
there is discussion about
languages have to grow or die javascript
is exempt from that as long as long as
there's a web it doesn't matter what
javascript is we're stuck with it so so
as long as we're stuck with it yeah I'm
gonna use it at the same time I am
hoping that someday we can obsolete it
and move on to something much better I
haven't seen that next language yet I
have gone out and talked appealed to
people design that new language and from
time to time some will come up to me and
say oh it's c-sharp yeah no it's not
c-sharp because so I'm waiting haven't
seen that the language that is enough
better than JavaScript too that does the
things that JavaScript does well we all
have to be the next universal language
I'm really hoping someone figures that
out yeah I want a really great
presentation was super interesting so
one of RO Fielding's architectural
constraints for web blog systems is that
that uniform interface of the URI of the
URL will will you keep that will like
internally as sets will be using URLs
can you link between the old web and the
new web you can link from yeah you can
link both ways so you could have a URL
in a safe application which will then
tell the old browser to display
something and this URL will tell the new
browser to display something that's all
everything else is different
oh very interesting talk but they have
questions and not you say that it's a
cell is like every puns new
vulnerabilities found but you're worse
mostly implementation not particle
itself and it's only because it is under
strict open I would eat but attention so
how are you going to make sure that your
own well your own security is under the
same myself attention so you make sure
that it's not wrong yeah we're going to
do that by making it much simpler and
and the codes are on github check it out
please tell me if I got it wrong I know
from the practice that it's really
really hard to find without deep deep
mathematical background any problems and
security and especially if you are
combining existing security like you are
doing right so if if your argument is we
should stay with the thing that we have
never gotten to work over 20 years no I
thought do you plan to go I told you
we're gonna do a thing which is much
simpler based on a much simpler model I
think simplicity is the only way to get
provable security and only time will
tell if my my assumption is correct at
this point I have no evidence to to show
that I did get it correct do you plan on
some OD certify certification something
exists from who says it's a question I'm
open to suggestions
okay then second question if you if
you'd like to certify it I think that'd
be swell well I can try
thank you
okay so let's maybe stop here let me ask
second question what last one for me you
tell that you are going to have all this
but names addresses public keys
everything this is not decentralized it
takes well much space for this
especially for mobile device for example
or it can be a problem space yes yes
you've got gigabytes of RAM everywhere
and especially if you have something
with secured elements inside or
something like this
so where you can make it secure so
that's the moment okay thank you very
much let's give a round of applause to
Douglas
[Applause]